hey guys welcome back to brand-new V
Rebecca a monster on a roll the game and
today we're just gonna go over this one
really quick quest that came up with a
tempered Basile geese called no tomorrow
for a usurpers yeah but with that like
the V if we do enjoy subscribe if you're
new I cover these solo guides for most
of the higher up monsters and monster
noir including battle gates which we'll
get into in a second so don't worry
about that as well as the event curse
every week to tell you which ones you're
supposed to be doing and what the
rewards are as well as tips and tricks
to make everyone a better monster on a
player so with that let's get started
with today's video like I said this new
quest is called no tomorrow for usurpers
and it basically has you fighting a
tempered Basile geese it is a star 9
quest and requires a char 30 minimum to
play this event quest and this is pretty
cool because it gives us bonus a char
upon completion now some people in the
game don't really need it they're
probably passed it 100 HR like myself so
I personally don't think I need the
extra HR but it never hurts to have some
in the future and for a quick review
tips for this flight bring flash pods
during this fight so you can flash him
during his dive bomb strafing run attack
which will lead into more damage which
will also break his skills as well since
that technically counts as a break of
parts since he is kind of ko'd and even
though it does less damage try to break
off his tail since that means less
scales that drop from there which will
make the fight way easier if you need
any more assistance with this video I
know bazevich is a pretty tough monster
especially the fact that he's tempered
now click the I on the top right of your
screen right now you'll be taken to one
of my full in-depth guides I did
embezzle geese himself although it is
from the HR 29 quest where there's two
tempered he still has the same move so
definitely some valuable information
there but going off his physiology
report his weakest to Thunder with ice
dragon sleep paralysis and poison all at
a close second his weakest points are
his head tail and wings all hunters
should be aiming for the head regardless
of a weapon you have except if it ranged
you can have a few bit more options so
you can also go for the head and the
wings if you wanted to as well to get
the maximum damage output and after that
it's done congratulations you now have
some extra HR for you to have the only
issue is that it seems like it's not as
much HR before then some of the other
quests like snow and cherry blossoms
which we all know which is one of the
most popular HR quests in the game which
is pretty weird it could be because I'm
a higher level or just the fact that the
quest doesn't give a much HR compared to
the other ones like I said with snow and
cherry blossoms but yeah it's going to
be the end of the video today but before
we leave I want to do something new
where at the end of every video I want
to show you guys a question
and you guys give me your thoughts about
the question and honest answers and we
start the discussion most of these
questions will basically be relevant to
the video but I'm not gonna ask you what
your opinions on bezel gates are since I
know most of everybody hates him so
we're gonna question for today's video
is gonna be what are you most excited
about for the summer festival the
festival is supposed to start around
July 12th that's apparently what it's
supposed to be and there will be news of
what is coming in so I'm very interested
in what you guys are excited for
personally for me I'm excited for the
new poogie outfit I know the hub lasses
are going to be getting new outfits
there's going to be new armor new stuff
tons and new things with this new
festival and the of course the
reoccurring event quests coming back
into the game but like I said I'm
personally excited for the new poogie
outfits I love that damn pig so much but
yeah but let me know what you guys think
in the comments below love to know your
thoughts and with that it's going to be
the end of the video today guys
hopefully you guys did enjoy it B I'd
like the V if you do enjoy subscribe for
new I cover the solo guides of most of
the monsters and Monster Hunter world
that being the hire of monsters like T
Ostrander cagin save as obese is you
know jiva all those monsters as well I
also come for the weekly event quest
just like this video to let you guys
know which ones are in the shop
currently or what's in the rotation and
what you should be doing and what the
rewards that come from it as well as the
tips and tricks to make everyone a
better Monster Hunter player with that
my two most recent videos will be on the
screen if you guys want to check that
out with that guys hope it's turday
think of watching the video and peace
out